>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERS ANOTHER PROMISE, AS A
UKRAINE NARRATIVE COMPLETELY
COLLAPSES, SPEAKER PELOSI SAYING
THAT A VOTE TO FORMALIZE THE
SECRET SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT
COUP ATTEMPT WILL TAKE PLACE
THIS WEEK BE HERE WITH REACTION
TO THAT, THE KILLING OF
BAGHDADI, SENATOR FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE CRITICAL OF THE
PRESIDENT.
AND I HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT TAKE AND I KNOW WHERE
YOU STAND IN THE MILITARY.
I KNOW WHY YOU WANT TO KEEP A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF TROOPS THEY
ARE SO ICES CAN'T BUILD BACK UP.
BUT HE'S THE ONE WHO TOOK THE
HANDCUFFS OFF OF OUR MILITARY,
GOT RID OF THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT AND BEAT THE
CALIPHATE.
NOW TOOK OUT BAGHDADI, I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT -- BY THE WAY,
THE KURDS, MY UNDERSTANDING,
THEY NOW CONTROL THE OIL FIELDS,
WHICH MEANS THEY'LL CONTROL
THEIR DESTINY WITH MORE MONEY
THEY EVER DREAMED OF.
AM I RIGHT?
>> YOU ARE TOTALLY RIGHT.
TRUMP ALLOWED THEM TO KILL THE
PHYSICAL PART OF THE CALIPHATE,
KILLED THE SPIRITUAL PART,
THAT'S LIKE WITHOUT HITLER
THAT'S LIKE NAZIS WITHOUT
HITLER, IF THAT KEEPS THE OIL
OUT OF IRAN, THAT'S A GOOD
STRATEGY.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF GUARDING THE
OIL, DEFEATING ICES BY DENYING
THEM THE OIL, CANOEING TO --
MR. PRESIDENT, KEEP YOUR FOOT ON
THE THROAT OF THE ICES FIGHTERS,
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T COME HERE.
IT WAS A BOLD MOVE, THE LEADER
OF THE CALIPHATE IS DEAD, SO
THIS IS A GOOD DAY FOR THE HOME
TEAM.
>> Sean: I BELIEVE WHATEVER
PROCEDURAL VOTE FOR THE HOUSE
WILL DO, IT'S BECAUSE YOU CALLED
THEM OUT.
EXCUSE ME, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
DO SECRET SOVIET STYLE TO ATTEND
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS LED BY A
CORRUPT COWARD COMPROMISED
SCHIFF, INSTEAD ON ARRIVAL WITH
THE SENATE, THE LAST PERSON
WHOEVER WANTS THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWERS TESTIFY WOULD BE
THE COWARD SCHIFF BECAUSE IF HE
DOES THAT, THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THEY MIGHT ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE CONTACT WITH YOU AND YOUR
CONTRACT, WHAT'S THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN YOU AND
JOE BIDEN, WILL BE SENT A DEMAND
QUESTIONS THOSE ANSWERS?
>> NUMBER ONE, BASED ON THE
PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND UKRAINIAN
PHONE CALL IS DEAD ON ARRIVAL IN
THE SENATE, HE DID NOTHING
WRONG.
I'VE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
MISCONDUCT BY THE PRESIDENT AT
ALL.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A SHAM.
THEY VOTE THURSDAY EIGHT -- WHAT
KIND OF PROCESS DO THEY GIVE THE
PRESIDENT?
WILL HE BE ABLE TO
IF YOU ARE GOING TO START THIS
PROCESS IN THE INTEL COMMITTEE,
IS IT INCUMBENT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS BECAUSE
WITHOUT THE WAS SOLD BLOWER,
THERE IS NO MEETING.
FIND OUT IF THEY HAVE ANY BIAS.
>> Sean: NEXT STEP, WE ARE
EXPECTING THE IG REPORT FINALLY
ON FISA ABUSE.
THE MEMO IS VERY CLEAR, HAS YOUR
NAME ON IT, THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION, THE PHIS
APPLICATIONS WHERE THE
UNVERIFIABLE DIRTY DOSSIERS AND
WE KNOW THE LIKES OF COMEY AND
OTHERS, THEY WERE WORN AS
MANY AS FIVE TIMES, DO NOT TRUST
THAT DOSSIER.
BUT THEY USED IT ANYWAY.
NOW WE KNOW BECAUSE STEELE WILL
VERIFY HIS OWN DOSSIER, I HAVE
NO IDEA WHEN THEY'LL MAKE ANY OF
IT IS TRUE WHEN PUSH CAME TO
SHOVE IT IN TIGER
IN AN ENTERIC
WHICH ENDED UP BEING A BACKDOOR
WITH A TRANSITION TEAM TO THE
PRESIDENT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HAPPENED
THE?
>> I DO.
I KNOW FOR SURE THEY WERE TOLD
STEELE WAS UNRELIABLE.
I KNOW FOR SURE THEY NEVER
INFORMED A COURT OF HIS BIAS.
ODDLY DEEP DOWN IN MY HEART, THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN WAS A SHAM,
PAPADOPOULOS -- I SPENT MORE
TIME WITH TRUMP THAN
PAPADOPOULOS -- THIS IS THE
BIGGEST CHANGE TO ME, IS THE
FACT THAT DURHAM HAS SUBPOENA
POWER, IS ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
CRIMINALITY.
SO HORWITZ WILL TELL US ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
I WILL LET YOU HEAR ABOUT IT IN
MY COMMITTEE UNDER OATH FOR ALL
THE WORLD TO SEE AND DURHAM IS
DOING HIS JOB.
JUST BACK TO NANCY PELOSI,
THERE'S NO WAY IN HILL SHE'D BE
HAVING THIS VOTE IN THE HOUSE
ALMOST 50 REPUBLICAN SENATORS
CALLED HER OUT.
IN A SHAM PROCESS.
>> Sean: I READ THE
TRANSCRIPT.
PRESIDENTS
WE HAVE A COURT AND UKRAINE
ADMIT AND FIND THAT THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS IMPORTANT.
TO ME, THE PRESIDENT DEMANDING
ANSWERS IS FAITHFULLY EXECUTING
HIS OATH OF THE CONSTITUTION.
WHAT BIDEN IS BRAGGING ABOUT ON
TAPE AND HIS SON WITH NO
EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE, ENERGY,
OIL, OR GAS, WHY ON EARTH WOULD
YOU GIVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
SOMEBODY WHO HAD NO EXPERIENCE,
SENATOR?
CAN YOU HELP ME WITH THAT?
>> SO THE DEMOCRAT BASICALLY IN
THIS CASE, BIDEN'S SON GOT MONEY
FROM UKRAINIAN ENTITIES TO BUY
INFLUENCE.
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
DONALD TRUMP MADE A PHONE CALL
THAT I FIND BEYOND ACCEPTABLE.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH THIS
PHONE CALL TO THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU ARE PLANNING TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP BASED ON THE
PHONE CALL, YOU ARE WASTING YOUR
TIME, TEARING THE COUNTRY APART
FOR NO GOOD REASON BECAUSE HE
DID NOTHING WRONG.
>> Sean: I AGREE.
AND I THINK -- LET THEM IMPEACH
HIM.
THE SENATE WON'T CONVICT HIM.
I BELIEVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE